okay so as far as the name Zach and Zoe
Sweet Bee Farm
Zack and Zoe
[Music]
so we found out that Zachary had
allergies we were in Brooklyn visiting
my husband's sister I'm in Williamsburg
and we ordered Thai food we found out
that they had Trina and peanut allergies
the hard way uh when it comes to
seasonal allergies just growing up it
was it wasn't like a huge detriment but
it's just rough just in the spring
always just like having to stay inside
so just hunker down just couldn't play
as much like sports and things they want
to but honey just kind of changed all
that
that honey is acting as an
anti-inflammatory agent and um calming
all the inflammation down at the same
time
[Music]
it was really my dad's ideas start
actually keeping bees and just having
them in the backyard at first it was
just like we were buying them my dad as
a mentor that we used to get honey from
all the time just like hey he just
switched gears like this could be our
own thing we keep our own bees so we got
some bees from him just set up in the
backyard and it's just been having more
and more highs ever since
I thought it would be exciting because
living out here you get a real
opportunity to like build your own kind
of farm
when we started beekeeping we had no
idea that there would be so many or so
much honey we really got an excess so we
gave it out to friends and family and
then we said you know what next year
let's start a little business with the
children they'll learn how to have a
business and the ins and outs of that
since dad's a businessman we got these
little labels going started to sell it
online a bit eventually we thought well
let's make it a little more serious
ended up being really really a good idea
we went to some artisanal markets and
started to sell the honey and it really
took off
[Music]
it's not small enough I hope so it
doesn't have to be a cool thing
stuff that's better A lot of smoky stuff
right back down that's not oh that works
okay yeah okay oh see how it that's yeah
that's perfect like yeah that's actually
a perfect like not too much not too
little
[Music]
so when you're out beekeeping you need
four things you need your B suit you
need a hive tool you need the smoker and
you need the bead brush basically the
smoker uh tricks the bees into thinking
there's a fire so they're more focused
on that situation than you going into
the hive and taking the honey we
approach The Hive as a team so one
person will usually be smoking and the
other will use the hive tool and lift up
the beehives and so we definitely need
to communicate with each other that's
one thing if you're beekeeping by
yourself then make sure you have both of
those ready just be alert and attentive
to what the bees are doing
[Music]
these are pollinators right so bees will
typically they eat pollen from the plant
and they also eat the nectar and they go
in ingest that with kind of enzymes in
their own body and that they reproduce
honey so that honey is a food source for
the bees it's a food source for their
young ones they'll eat the honey but
they'll also store it and save it as
their food source for the winter time
foreign
hundreds of types of of Honey depending
on the Floral Source you've got honey
that's got more of a you know a
blueberry honey that are pollinating the
blueberry Groves or the Cranberry Bogs
um even you know honey that's
pollinating the California almonds has a
different like a more of a nuttier you
know profile than you know honey that is
just more more of a Floral Source and so
it really is fascinating to understand
and just taste the different notes and
to see you know all honey is not the
same and so it's really cool to just see
people experience it
foreign
[Music]
once you go into the hive you've taken
off all the protective coverings there's
about nine frames in each box and so
you're gonna remove a frame to harvest
the honey we're just taking out one for
breakfast tomorrow and so when you take
the frame out you just make sure that
there's honey on it first of all and
that it's not a frame that might have
babies in it brood they call it when
there's honey in it they'll have little
capsules over it so you'll see the same
sort of hexagon pattern where there's
honey or whether it's out honey but when
there's no honey there there's just not
you will see the little cap over it
where's we're not getting stored so like
us the bees are storing up food for the
winter and here in North America
essentially that's an important part of
their day they're thinking about how to
make sure they have enough for the Queen
the whole Hive The Brood just to make it
through the winter so you don't want to
take too much honey when you're
harvesting you want to make sure they
have enough food to make it through to
the next warm season
when you brush the bees off to get your
honey they're just brush them back into
the hive usually just down motion
straight back ends they don't have to
get like infused or days they'll just be
right back where they belong and just
make sure they're not left they don't
want just like one last bee around your
house just
it is that you're brave so if you want
honey all you have to do is have some
courage and enjoy yourself
foreign
at first I thought mixing superfoods
with the honey would be really strange
and it wouldn't really take off but once
Ma I tried it it tasted amazing and
everyone we sold it to really really
loved the idea
[Music]
I would go to like organic markets and
when I would look at the shelves I was
like how are we going to fit to stand
out I just said well let's add matcha
let's add you know raspberries let's add
Ginger yeah Lavender is a big one the
hot honey just came out last year oh
cardamom if you haven't tried the card
it's just like buy the Spoonful but yeah
there's plenty of options that you can
choose from there's like 23 right now
[Music]
once you bring a frame in there's
something called an extractor
[Music]
so you have a big barrel and then inside
there's just something that spins that
aren't honey right out of there all the
honey just goes to the bottom of the
whole machine it goes right into the
barrel with the top yeah with the tap on
it and those barrels go to our
Production Studio
we bring the honey in
um from the trucks and we take the lids
off Stir It Up Make sure this they're
nice and settled and mixed properly then
we take them and put them into the
reservoir the machine holds the honey
and then it's pumped up into a larger
machine where the superfoods are at it
and that's where the magic happens
then just the employees come and jar
them very easily and we're able to label
them in the labeling machine put them in
the box and then they're ready to go so
everything you get is just really
literally that honey and that organic
superfood and that's the only process
really that we have going there
so a lot of the honey goes out to direct
to Consumer others go to larger
retailers but a portion of it goes to
Chelsea Market where we're able to sell
it face to face
[Music]
the best part about Chelsea is just
everything but the neighborhood is what
we are so excited about and having a
spot there is like has been epic for us
interacting with the customers people
all over the world an amazing experience
so bring in the honey as a family we
have a good time with it sell and we
have an amazing team that works there
too people have said to us like your you
know Orchestra are so sweet
I'm like it's the
honeymoon
after that we just make sure that the
customers are satisfied and everything
is running smoothly and at the end of
the day if everyone has their honey then
we're good to go
[Music]
[Laughter]
the kids have literally grown up with
bees and so it's fun because as they get
older I mean Zach is 14 Zoe is 15 and
gonna be 16 next week as they get more
independent you miss the moments and the
times you spend with them and so it's a
little little Bittersweet I mean you're
you're happy to see your kids grow up
but you certainly miss them and you miss
the memories and you you know miss them
uh putting on you know the bee suits or
holding the smoker for Dad or bringing
me the um the hive tool so you know
hopefully right when they get older and
and get married their kids want to come
spend time with grandpa doing uh doing B
work so we'll see foreign
the business started it began to become
tied with my upbringing and even before
I felt like that we were prepared to be
raised into this business and we were
equipped with the skills to keep the
business running forward even after like
Mom and Dad eventually like retire I
don't really don't seem like the type to
retired she kept saying oh I'm never
gonna drive but
um yeah I'm really really grateful for
that that we have something that has set
us up for some serious success
it's a lot to have a business with your
name on it it's just like a big deal and
I like paying my own dad of course
because they did most of the heavy
lifting obviously you can't really run a
business when you're seven but like it's
definitely just a huge thing that's like
just kind of a part of me now just like
I like pitch and help just something on
my mind I'm always thinking about just
what's new and like what's coming up
over the horizon but it's like a just a
nice State of Mind to be in just hey
like this is my own thing and this is
something I'll like eventually have to
just carry on my own like I can't run
the business forever so I was just like
it's not gonna be my own thing in the
future just big deal for me
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]